aujourd'hui elle date 10 à un peu moins
d'une demi heure c'est la victoire de
yannick jadot à la primaire europe
ecologie les verts
51,03 % on va analyser ce score un score
serré qui donne aussi de poids politique
à sandrine rousseau on va également vous
dévoiler les résultats du baromètre
politique de notre partenaire au doxa
avec des surprises concernant la
popularité du présent un public mais
aussi concernant eric zemmour en tête
des personnalités politiques les plus
rejeter le prix du gaz va augmenter de
plus de 12 % dès la semaine prochaine
c'est la mauvaise nouvelle du jour ce
sera le thème des électeurs ont la
parole vous pouvez réagir avec le mot
diez le hashtag sens public on parlera
donc précarité énergétique
tout à l'heure et puis pour notre débat
décalé on va décortiquer une promesse de
campagne la nationalisation des
autoroutes idée neuve où il écourte
idées partagées en tout cas marine le
pen et arnaud montebourg on en fait une
proposition de leur campagne
on commence tout de suite par la fin du
suspense chez les verts ils ont donc
choisi leur champion ce ne sera pas une
championne pour 2022 et c'est julien
bayou le secrétaire national qui l'a
annoncé tout à l'heure
on a donc une participation extrêmement
importante de 85 41 % c'est sans 4772
personnes qui ont participé à ce second
tour
on à
2464 vote blanc soit 2 35 % des votants
et pour s'impliquer je vais vous donner
les résultats des deux finalistes
yannick jadot avec 51 0 3% c'est 50 de
1210 voix et sandrine rousseau avec 48
97 % ces cinquante mille
0,98 voit notre candidat pour la
présidentielle le candidat de l'ensemble
des écologistes c'est donc yannick jadot
et on va tout de suite commenté ce
résultat avec mai invitée bonsoir gail
simone bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes le
président de doxa vous publiez votre
baromètre politique mensuel et vous
serez présent sur ce plateau parce que
public sénat est partenaire de ce notre
sonomètre voilà on est d'accord et d'où
vous viendrez chaque mois en analyser
les les résultats et là on va commencer
évidemment par l'actualité europe
ecologie les verts j'accueille également
julia mouzon bonsoir et bienvenue vous
est la fondatrice d'élu local élu es élu
local point fr membre du haut conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
pierre jacqmin bonsoir bonsoir rédacteur
en chef de la revue regards j'ai ici le
dernier numéro l'ère du bruit
effectivement cette campagne promet les
deux rues brouillon on va essayer ici de
de l'analyse et d'une façon un peu un
peu apaisées même si évidemment toutes
les opinions peuvent s'exprimer
j'accueille également laëtitia kamba
bonsoir laetitia éditorialistes
politiques présentes sur sur le plateau
de sens public tous les mardis et tous
les jeudis c'est donc qu'ils ganic jadot
qui va porter le drapeau des verts pour
pour cette présidentielle
51,03 % pour l'eurodéputé l'ancien
directeur
des campagnes de greenpeace galeski van
asch aulas comment vous analysé ce
résultat ouf ouf pour lui ouf pour les
écologistes parce que c'est très serré
que c'est celui qui était perçu par les
français et les électeurs écologistes
comme le meilleur candidat pour porter
leurs couleurs alors par ailleurs dans
les intentions de vote c'est celui aussi
qui réalisait le meilleur score pour
europe ecologie les verts et c'était pas
gagné quand on regardait le résultat du
premier tour de cette primaire eh bien
on peut dire que les 22 % d'électeurs
qui avaient volts qui avaient voté pour
delphine batho
ou pour eric piolle on aurait pu
personne ne savait rien ce n'est le
brouillard complet mais on aurait pu
imaginer qu'ils auraient eu davantage
tendance à se reporter sur sandrine
rousseau que sur yannick jadot j'ajoute
que dans notre baromètre politique on
voit des écarts considérables de de
popularité de code d'adhésion entre lui
et sandrine rousseau mais elle avait un
immense atout relevé par denso
consulting le partenaire avec lequel
nous nous réalisons ensemble baromètre
politique sur les réseaux sociaux sur
internet depuis ces dernières semaines
souvent pour en dire du mal mais en tout
cas elle a fait le buzz c'était honnête
elle a écrasé tout le monde en termes de
visibilité le plus souvent pour
critiquer ses positions enfin vous
connaissez l'adage un parlez moi de
parler de moi en bien parlez de moi en
mal l'essentiel est que vous parliez de
moi pour elle ça s'est vérifié ça lui a
permis de réaliser quand même un très
bon score et au premier tour et au
second tour oui on parlera évidemment de
la personnalité de l'avenir de sandrine
rousseau j'aimerais vous entendre l'une
et l'autre sur ceux où se prononcer par
gaël sliman qui forcément vous fait
réagir julia muzeau ouais en fait il ya
deux choses pour moi qui se détache de
ce résultat le premier c'est que l'enjeu
de ce trimestre politique c'est l'union
c'est vrai pour les autres partis
politiques et c'est vrai en particulier
pour europe ecologie les verts chez qui
on a vu au premier tour des résultats
très divisée avec des candidats qui
obtenait tous plus de 20% et sur lequel
le deuxième tour est très serré entre
sandrine rousseau et yannick jadot donc
on sent bien que derrière l'union est
derrière le gagnant le parti va devoir
opérer un rassemblement sur des
fractures idéologiques qui ne sont pas
évidentes entre la décroissance et la
croissance verte entre la radicalité et
l'écologie de gouvernement il ya
maintenant un vrai travail à faire en
interne au sein d'europe écologie les
verts sur ce rassemblement n'a plus les
cartes crs qui veut absolument le
rassemblement est le deuxième point
c'est que sandrine rousseau est une
femme yannick jadot est un homme donc
évidemment
regarde de toutes parts si une femme va
émerger pour pour cette présidentielle
alors voilà dehors de marine le pen qui
a déjà émergé voilà mes mais c'est
intéressant de voir à la fois cette
popularité renforcée sur les réseaux
sociaux et en même temps comme vos
collègues de quotidiens l'on pointé il
ya quelques jours on a une moindre
présence des femmes présidentiables dans
les espaces médiatiques les plus
visibles et les plus vues dans les
matinales en fait les soldes sont
présents dans les hommes elles sont bien
moins bien exposées que les hommes dans
l'espace médiatique et ça peut expliquer
c'est décrochage sur des questions plus
impalpables de légitimité ou on se dit
est-ce qu'elle a la carrure à ce cas là
les épaules et uss cette absence ou ce
recul des endroits les plus prestigieux
se faire marie pour en reparler tout à
l'heure sur le duel enfin d'ailleurs
c'est ça va un peu plus loin qu'un duel
entre xavier bertrand et michel barnier
pierre jacqmin votre votre analyse de ce
résultat là aussi h aux halles on a eu
l'info 20 25 minutes avant de prendre
l'antenne je crois que c'est le pire que
ce qu'ils de ce qui pouvait arriver aux
écologistes c'est un score extrêmement
serré yannick jadot était parti grand
favori ça peut-être d'ailleurs la
surprise de cette élection puisque on
avait dit que les surprises c'était
justement l inverse de ce qui était
attendu et jadot était quand même celui
qui devait être presque d'ailleurs
pensait-il élu au premier tour avec un
score très net là ça n'est pas le cas
donc je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour les écologistes
d'abord parce qu il y montre qu'ils sont
divisés sur deux lignes de fracture qui
sont pas des petites lignes de fracture
vous l'avais dit je pense qu'ils vont
avoir un travail de reconsolidation en
tout cas de rassemblement qui va être
très important que les cfl autre
mauvaise nouvelle aux prises depuis un
an c'est vrai c'est vrai découverte et à
la campagne sans doute sauf que là elles
ont été d'autant plus exacerbé qui a une
vraie belle primaire je trouve avec des
débats qui ont été très intéressants où
on a vu justement les différences qui ne
sont pas je ne crois pas que ce soit des
petites différences 50 delphine batho
parle de décroissance et que yannick
jadot parle de croissance verte on sent
déjà qu effectivement ce que reprochent
les écologies d'une manière générale de
la politique telle qu'elle est appliquée
au gouvernement c'est la politique des
petits pas est ce qui est reproché à
monsieur jadot c'est justement cette
volonté d'avancer petit à petit de ne
pas créer de véritables ruptures donc je
pense que c'est en cela que c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour les écologistes
parce qu'ils doivent se rassembler et
puis c'est aussi la mauvaise nouvelle
pour anne hidalgo parce que ces
embouteillages avec la candidature de
yannick jadot de la social démocratie
dite verte et puis
deux candidatures qui se ressent bien
dit jadot anne hidalgo et peut-être du
coup effectivement un boulevard donné à
jean luc mélenchon qu'ils s'en doute va
passer un coup de fil à sandrine
rousseau qui pèse du coup électoral
manqué un acquéreur qui sort renforcée
de cette de cette campagne électorale
qui est une belle campagne alors à
l'écouté justement sandrine rousseau
c'était yahia l'instant soutien affiché
à yannick jadot mais elle se projette
aussi vers l'avenir nous avons montré
dans cette primaire que nous pouvons
changer la politique nous avons porté
une nouvelle voie dans cette campagne
une nouvelle manière d'incarner
l'engagement nous n'attendrons pas un
quinquennat de plus ensemble avec tous
les écologistes nous sommes en capacité
de relever les défis et de gagner la
présidentielle
vous pouvez compter sur moi pour
soutenir la suite de cette aventure
c'est laetitia c'est loin d'être la fin
de l'histoire effectivement c'est
peut-être même le début pour pour
sandrine rousseau pourquoi s'est
démarqué elle s'est démarquée parce
qu'elle colle complètement à l'époque et
elle a su maîtriser de bout en bout son
storytelling avec son histoire
personnelle puisqu'elle a expliqué
pourquoi elle était revenu en politique
après laffaire baupin le député européen
qu'elle a accusé d'agression sexuelle et
qui a été classé parce qu'il y avait
prescription elle s'était retiré de la
politique et l a dit quand emmanuel
macron a nommé gérald darmanin intérieur
qui lui même était accusé d'agression
sexuelle et de viol je n'ai pas sûrs
dont lieu de plus voilà je n'ai pas plus
je n'ai pas pu rester chez moi à isoler
et j'ai voulu revenir dans le combat
politique ça c'est un storytelling qui
est très fort parce que et avait
évidemment tout tout lhermitte où on
était dans ce climat d'un retour d'un
néo féminisme et justement elle revient
avec un concept qui existe depuis les
années 70 mais qu'elle a remis au goût
du jour et qui collent encore une fois
totalement à notre ère qui est
l'écoféminisme c'est à dire c'est la
rencontre entre l'écologie et le
féminisme et donc sa part du principe
qu'il ya une prédation c'est un mot qui
répète qu'elle répète souvent une
prédation soit des hommes sur les femmes
ou des humains sur la nature donc elle
arrive avec un storytelling qui est très
très fort et des concepts et un message
que tout le monde peut comprendre
et qui sont relativement novateur en
fait dans le monde politique il ya aussi
la radicalité elle en a fait une sorte
de marque de fabrique oui elle le répète
si toujours et remarquée dans une
interview vous parliez madame de
radicalité versus la modération cologie
de gouverner de gouvernement y met
finalement yannick jadot lui même a dit
c'était sur france inter mais moi aussi
je suis un radical moi aussi j'ai
arraché des ogm voyez donc chacun se
réclamer d'une action un peu radicale
pour montrer que ça va les muscles
s'était pas sandrine rousseau lui aussi
en avait comme on dit en politique on
sait que ça compte en coulisse
évidemment je le dis sur le plateau mais
c'est vraiment des termes qui reviennent
souvent dans le combat politique et donc
forcément elle amène sa radicalité et
forcément elle va peser aussi dans la
candidature jadot qui va devoir se
positionner cette façon là je viens vous
en vous diriez que l'écoféminisme a
trouvé là son incarnation est-ce qu'on
peut aller jusque là oui je pense qu'on
peut aller jusque là alors dans un parti
politique qui porte aussi l'écoféminisme
de façon très forte comme on l'a vu et
de façon différente de la société
française les adhérents d'europe
écologie les verts ne vote pas de la
même façon que la société française et
les résultats auraient sans doute été
différent si si ça avait été un second
tour par exemple d'élection
présidentielle mais oui absolument à la
fois sur la partie féminisme et sur la
partie écologie on peut d'ailleurs gaël
sliman reprendre le baromètre au doxa de
ce mois de septembre justement sur ces
ce comparatif jadot rousseau le
sentiment d'adhésion chez les
sympathisants de gauche on avait 1 45%
pour yannick jadot en forte hausse et
une housse andino soit 31% et puis sur
l'ensemble des français yannick jadot à
19 + 4 % et sans une reçoit à 12% et on
est en hausse par rapport à avril et
surtout on avait déjà testé ça nous
avait été reproché figurez-vous part par
une partie des écologistes au moment du
premier tour dans un précédent sondage
on a fait une chose qu'on fait quasiment
à chaque élection où à chaque primaire
on avait demandé aux français et parmi
eux aux sympathisants de l'ensemble des
partis de gauche et parmi eux on avait
regardé quand même en disant attention
il ya des grosses marges d'erreur
statistique on est sur des petits
échantillons ce que pensaient les
sympathisants écologie et on leur avait
dit parmi les différents candidats
lequel vous préféreriez en disant bien
c'est pas une intention de vote c'est
pas les militants écologistes on a
interrogé c'est pas les électeurs de
cette primaire écologiste et le résultat
était évidemment je dis évidemment pas
ce que vous pouviez vous y attendre
comme vous le suggérez y est très
favorable à yannick jadot mais déjà
peut-être un peu moins que ce que
j'aurais imaginé il ne dépassait pas les
50 % auprès des français il était il
avait une quinzaine une vingtaine de
points d'avancé sur sandrine rousseau et
delphine batho auprès des sympathisants
de gauche dans leur ensemble et idem
auprès des sympathisants et électeurs
d'europe écologie les verts et
écologistes en général donc on a
systématiquement vous l'évoquez je crois
madame un écart important entre ce que
choisissent les adhérents les militants
les l'écosystème le noyau dur
écologistes et l'électorat écologiste à
une élection présidentielle
et plus encore les français on l'avait
vécu avec nicolas hulot et eva joly et
je l'avais vécu alors que j'étais de
tous tout jeune sondeurs il ya une
vingtaine d'années puisque dans le cadre
de notre travail à l'époque j'étais à
bba on avait un rendez vous avec noël
mamère qui était prévu avant le vote de
ce qu'on appellera la primaire enfin les
adhérents écologistes et c'était lui le
grand favori on imaginait été beaucoup
plus connu que les autres et finalement
il a été battu par alain lipietz à
l'époque mais alors juste et ça c'est
quasiment systématique c'est lui là bas
c'est la wii mais justement qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont passer de très doux et s4
pierre jacqmin c'est pas un signe de
maturité politique d'europe écologie les
verts finalement d'avoir quand même
choisi le favori celui qui peut
peut-être faire une perf je ne sais pas
on perd ses dents dont l'opinion en
dehors du parti de lui-même peut-être on
reste quand même dans des niveaux en
tout cas tel que les sondeurs test
le candidat
yannick jadot dans des proportions qui
sont quand même relativement faible vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure les sondages qui
avait été fait sur sandrine rousseau et
yannick jadot certes sandrine rousseau
démarré à 2 3% - yannick jadot tourne
autour de 5,6 parfois 7% il s'en donne
rousseau on la connaît véritablement
enfin les français le connaissent
véritablement depuis quinze jours allez
peut-être un mot on va dire donc c'est à
prendre en considération c'est vrai que
c'est un gros saut et est en dynamique
c'est ce qui risque d'ailleurs d'être
compliqué pour yannick jadot
c'est-à-dire d'impulser une nouvelle
dynamique qui était plutôt du côté de de
sandrine rousseau donc je crois que là
il ya un enjeu absolument colossal pour
les écologistes et puis comme vous le
disiez certes peut-être qu'ils sont
arrivés à maturité mais peut être aussi
qu'ils sont capables de retrouver et de
renouer avec les travers du passé on
sait pas on sait jamais et ce peut-être
que semblait brousseau on peut
considérer que son candidat ça n'est pas
naturellement yannick jadot selon la
compagnie mélenchon
on a vu par le passé des candidats qui
ont été remplacés par d'autres chez les
écologistes on a vu la merde récemment
beaucoup d'écologistes qui étaient
engagés dans des primaires rejoindre le
camp macron plutôt que de rejoindre le
camp qui était celui des écologistes qui
était bonne maman donc tout est possible
chez les écologistes tout est possible
tout est encore possible
julien voulzy ça profite à qui ce
résultat d'abord à jean luc mélenchon
effectivement d'accord avec cette idée
oui oui tout à fait je suis d'accord
avec cette idée c'est vrai que sandrine
rousseau incarne donc est une femme et
incarne des valeurs qui sont plus
radicale que celle de yannick jadot qui
va nécessairement aller davantage sur
les plates-bandes si on peut dire de
anne hidalgo et al'inverse laisser un
espace à gauche à jean luc mélenchon ça
on va pouvoir le vérifier dans l'est
dans les prochains jours vois moi je
pense quand je disais ouf tout à l'heure
je prends pas position politique
politiquement moi évidemment de par mes
fonctions c'était ouf pour les
écologistes parce qu'il ya un résultat
parce qu'a priori ce qu on a
l'impression que sandrine rousseau
reconnaît sa défaite elle n'a pas de
nommer dans ce que j'ai entendu un jeu
ça vient d'arriver mais j'ai pas entendu
qu'elle nommait je soutiendrai yannick
jadot coeur à l'aller on a appris
c'est quand même un on a vu des
politiques dans d'autres partis réagir
de manière moins fair-play donc ouf pour
tout ça et ouf quand même parce que le
positionnement de niche sur lequel et
sandrine rousseau on peut pas faire je
n'ai pas de boule de cristal on peut
pronostiquer ni même à partir des
intentions de vote actuels mais rend
quand même plus compliqué la possibilité
d'agréger un grand nombre d'électeurs
yannick jadot peut très bien rester à 5
7% peut tomber à 2 tout peut arriver
mais ce qu'il incarne politiquement si
ça marche qui s'apprend avec la baisse
d'anne hidalgo dans les sondages peu
peut permettre de faire un meilleur
score que celui dont il est crédité
aujourd'hui par un retrait de lagun aro
sélection nuit cette année de louis vous
avez à fait raison comme tout est
possible et encore plus à mon avis pour
cette élection nouvelle en 2022 à
présidentielle pourquoi pas à hidalgo si
elles chutent vraiment dans les sondages
parce qu'on sait aussi que ce sera
beaucoup une élection fait avec les
sondages avec l'opinion donc pourquoi
pas un ralliement de dernière minute à
yannick jadot ci le lui réussi à monter
ici la soutiens de sandrine rousseau je
vous donnais juste un petit indice si
normalement le scénario tient parce
qu'on sait que la mise en scène
politique est fondamental dans ce genre
de moments de séquences ils devraient
arriver ensemble ce soir devant les
militants et prendre la parole juste
avant le 20h de yannick jadot donc il se
présente avec sandrine rousseau cheville
ouvrière de sa victoire donc il
reconnaît aussi la part de sandrine
rousseau dans le combat qu'ils ont amené
oui bien sûr qui lui donnera enfin en
tout cas moi je suis passé un sac en c1
enfin il lui donnera évidemment un rôle
prépondérant oui on peut même dire que
sans donner au saut était une sorte de
vitrine de
dès qu'ils montent à gauche et que
yannick jadot je viens on va devoir
tenir compte en aillant il est présent
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps qu'elle
dans le dans l'espace politique enfin
vous parliez des résultats de 2008 2009
et de 2008 ebit 2002 avec ma mère lit
qu'en fait il ya eu 2011 en 2011 eva
joly a gagné alors qu'on attendait
nicolas hulot en 2016 2016 avant 2017
voilà jadot a gagné alors qu'on
attendait cécile duflot qui était plus
populaire donc c'est vrai qu'on est à
rebours des résultats classent zielinger
lipietz en 2002 ouais et que et que et
que sandrine rosol du coup amène dans
cette
danse est historique politique un regard
frais un storytelling effectivement une
histoire une incarnation un engagement
une authenticité aussi puisqu'on l'a vu
vraiment
enfin 13 au nom très honnête et très
authentique sur les plateaux télé donc
une authenticité une honnêteté qui donne
un vrai vent de fraîcheur à cette la
suite des ratés en baggy son
contemporain et qui sont dans la société
dans ses marques de sorcières tout le
monde la rai et quand elle parle de
sorcières c'est une figure extrêmement
populaire chez les nouvelles féministes
dans les marches pour le climat du
vendredi il y avait beaucoup de
pancartes qui voit là faisait appel à
cette figure de la sorcière pour les
jeunes tu voulais qu'ils défilent pour
le climat c'est à dire peut-être un
réservoir de votants ces futurs cédants
juin dernier j'en tire à dernier aussi
ce sujet il est porté de raisons
beaucoup plus large que ça me relancer
parce que sorcières c'est le titre d'un
livre de mona chollet qui après bien un
mot de conclusion sur les pierres qui
sera véritablement un atout pour yannick
jadot de mobilisation de la jeunesse et
des femmes j'en suis absolument
convaincu
alors moi je veux juste mettre un tout
petit bémol parce que dans notre
baromètre politique on a vous avez
évoqué 12% de code d'adhésion elle clive
où on peut le dire on n'en a pas on
parlera d'eric zemmour en est risible on
en parle beaucoup il clive énormément
mais eric zemmour il ya trois fois plus
de gens qui le détestent que de gens qui
l'apprécient sandrine rousseau c'est
presque quatre fois plus vous avez 41%
des n'a pas gagné mais ces femmes
maintenance non mais je dis ça mais je
dis ça c'est important de l'avoir en
tête 41 % de code de rejet c'est
extrêmement violent contre 12%
d'adhésion donc je disais ça par rapport
à votre idée est ce que ça va être un
atout est ce que yannick jadot de
l'utiliser à mon avis tactiquement il a
intérêt évidemment à venir maintenant la
main avec elle ce soir à montrer qu'ils
sont qu'ils sont alliés que voilà tout
le courant passe bien entre eux si j'ose
dire mais attention parce qu'elle peut
aussi être un repoussoir pour un
candidat qui veut élargir sa base alors
nous on va élargir le l'analyse de votre
baromètre
mensuel beaucoup d'enseignements à tirer
notamment concernant la droite et le
président la république une synthèse
signé sandra pardon
malgré l'espace médiatique qu'il occupe
et une progression des intentions de
vote depuis juillet eric zemmour est en
bas du classement du dernier sondage aux
hawks à
59% des sondés déclarent éprouver du
rejet à son égard soit près de deux
tiers des français
davantage que jean luc mélenchon et
marine le pen autre enseignement de ce
sondage à six mois de la présidentielle
emmanuel macron reste apprécié et
soutenu par 42% des français qui voient
en lui un bon président selon l'institut
c'est même un score de popularité
meilleurs que ceux de ces deux derniers
prédécesseurs à la même époque à droite
xavier bertrand confirme sa place de
favori choisi par 60% des sympathisants
et l'air il est préféré à valérie
pécresse qui recueille 42% d'opinions
favorables et devient plus populaire que
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe
à droite toujours michel barnier
l'ancien négociateur du breakbeat
candidat à l'investiture à droite
progresse avec 46% de popularité il
arrive en sixième position
enfin à gauche jean luc mélenchon gagne
11 points depuis juillet et anne hidalgo
9 points auprès des sympathisants de
gauche
bon évidemment on va analyser c'est ce
score concernant eric zemmour dans un
instant mais devrait démarrer par par la
droite par le parti lr gaël sliman un
candidat je vais reprendre les chiffres
on revient de on va les voir ah tiens on
va les voir pardon je suis en train de
réfléchir tout le temps avec jonathan du
prix est ce que j'ai vu ses baskets qui
apparaissait la voilà et donc je
l'attends c'est le bon moment en fait
parce que si moi je donne les résultats
vous voulez donner ça va pas le faire ça
prend quand même beaucoup de réactions
chez l air ce cette prime ou en tout cas
cette avance prise par xavier bertrand
expliqué nous oui tout à fait et surtout
chez les partisans de moussavi et
bertrand qui évidemment ils voient voir
en tout cas la bonne dynamique de leur
champion comme une aubaine sur laquelle
il faut capitaliser un autre baromètre
aux hawks à dentsu consulting publié
aujourd'hui montre d'ailleurs cette
bonne dynamique et que xavier bertrand
creuse l'écart sur les autres
prétendants à droite évidemment il est
testé or rassemblement national alors si
on s'attarde sur le panel prenant en
compte l'ensemble des français près d'un
sondé sur deux soit 49 % des personnes
qui ont répondu à l enquête désigne
xavier bertrand comme à la personnalité
de droite dont il se sent le plus proche
ces sept points de plus que sa
principale rivale valérie pécresse alors
ça c'est pour le global auprès des
sympathisants de droite maintenant et
bien là le président de la région de
france important en marge du parti des
républicains il est bien il conforte un
petit peu plus son statut de favori il
est même plébiscitée par 57% des sondés
vous le voyez contre 38% pour valérie
pécresse son homologue en ile-de-france
alors c'est très bon indicateur 1 donne
des ailes au camp bertrand dont les
soutiens presse pour que les autres
candidats déclarés sorange d'ores et
déjà derrière lui avant le congrès du 4
décembre avant que i l investiture
officielle du candidat écoutez ses porte
parole au micro son brassard cas plutôt
on pourra réellement partir en campagne
tous unis tous unis mieux ce sera c'est
évident mais la balle est dans le camp
des républicains ils ont un calendrier
peuvent-ils veulent t'ils l'accélérer
peut toujours accélérer les choses le
congrès de trains congrès de
rassemblement et non pas un congrès
d'affrontements et moi j'ai vraiment bon
espoir que l'ensemble des personnalités
qui composent notre famille politique eh
bien tous se responsabilisent et tous
considèrent qu'il faut se ranger
rien le candidat qui sera le mieux placé
aujourd'hui incontestablement c'est
xavier bertrand voilà thomas donc vous
l'avez entendu à l'idée est bien
d'entrer le plus vite possible dans une
campagne pour le moment les républicains
apparaissent un peu empêtré dans leur
recherche du candidat idéal et des
bisbilles autour du calendrier est ce
que ça risque d'aggraver des divisions
internes au sein des leurs oui en tout
cas on a déjà l'impression que la
situation est en train de s'envenimer 1
au sein de l air notre face aux coups de
boutoir du clan bertrand michel barnier
qui lui aussi est un candidat qui a une
bonne dynamique sont d'agir et bien le
camp barney a lancé une contre-offensive
c'était le figaro qui a publié cette
lettre adressée à christian jacob ou
l'ancien négociateur en chef du brésil
demande au patron de l air d'actes et je
le cite la date du 4 décembre comme si
ça n'allait pas de soi et d'organiser
sans délai dit il un grand débat entre
tous les candidats déclarés en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que ces questions
elles vont créer du débat au sein de l
heure est peut-être dès ce soir au
comité stratégique rue de vaugirard
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
détailler jonathan se ces chiffres
leslie match où je vais pas vous
demander de recommencer les chiens de
notre je n'ai plus rien à dire jeudi si
vous êtes hyper important dans
l'histoire de la rcr qu'on a
l'impression que ce seront ceux c'est
votre travail vous êtes en train de
faire monter le wifaq l'opinion mais
n'est pas derrière mais il était en
train de faire monter la légitimité du
candidat naturel temps oui vous avez
raison et bien ses responsabilités
non mais c'est trop s'est pas c'est pas
raisonnable même ster que on a le
sentiment que on va avoir un candidat
désigné par les sondages avec alors six
mois qui suit sondeurs qui le dit et
qu'il déplore avec des sondages qui
s'autoalimente sens sans volonté de
manipuler mais c'est un fait que si vous
avez un petit ascendant
il ya des fables qui existe comme ça
vous avez aujourd'hui xavier bertrand un
petit ascendant sur valérie pécresse
dans les intentions de vote à la
présidentielle
il espérait creuser l'écart pendant
l'été il n'y est pas parvenu quand vous
regardez les différents instituts leurs
intentions de vote il ya toujours quand
c'est l'hypothèse bertrand un avantage
sur l'hypothèse pécresse
sa joie points deux points c'est pas
énorme c'est pas déterminant et on sait
très bien que des sondages à sept mois
d'une élection
ça ne dit rien des chances d'un candidat
or ce sondage du jour où on demande aux
gens qu'ils préfèrent entre xavier
bertrand et valérie pécresse on a
d'autres questions qui nous montrent
qu'en partie les sympathisants de droite
disent bas comme j'ai vu dans l'essor
entre guillemets dans les sondages entre
parenthèses dans les sondages que xavier
bertrand avait plus de chances que
valérie pécresse parce qu'il était un
peu de vent dans les intentions de vote
ça vient s'autoalimenter moi ce que
j'observe c'est que dans des situations
en réalité de deux tours les tests
séparément comme sur la côte d'adhésion
à xavier bertrand est préférée il a un
niveau de cote d'adhésion un peu
supérieurs mais valérie pécresse n'est
pas loin donc il ya deux aujourd'hui
deux candidats qui aurait l'assentiment
qui séduirait l'électorat de droite il y
en a un qui a un peu devant l'autre et
effectivement ce n'est sans doute pas le
rôle des sondages de déterminer lequel
des deux est le meilleur parce qu'ils
sont tous les deux connu et très
apprécié par leur base sympathisante ou
des lecteurs moi je pense que les
militants doivent faire leur choix en
fonction de leurs convictions des
projets de l'un et l'autre sans spéculer
sur lequel serait le meilleur
julie à mauzens et on imagine mal
valérie pécresse ont même michel barnier
céder facilement c'est c'est pas la
tonalité du moment non c'est pas du tout
la tonalité du moment ça donne vraiment
le sentiment que tous les candidats a
déclaré aujourd'hui il rompt jusqu'au
congrès du 4 décembre congrès choisit
d'ailleurs par rapport à une primaire on
l'a vu les primaires divisent et
primaire nécessite après une
réconciliation un congrès c'est un
moment qui permet davantage de se
retrouver donc je pense que c'est aussi
pour ça que le congrès a été préféré à
la primaire qui est plus clivante et non
on sent pas aujourd'hui cette logique là
après xavier bertrand c'est vraiment
pour rebondir ce ce que disait gaël
sliman xavier bertrand est vraiment le
candidat de la france des territoires et
il s'inscrit pleinement dans cette
stratégie politique on pourrait dire
poste gilet jaune avec une présence à la
fête du haricot à soissons avec des
échanges avec les maires avec cette
recherche de l'eau qualité et de
proximité qui est très forte dans les
attentes des français et qui peut
manquer ipcress les avantages en de
région ou même à michel barnier alors
qu'ils manquent davantage à valérie
pécresse présidente d'une région très
urbaine mais dont on voit dans l'exemple
extrême d'anne hidalgo qu'elle n'est pas
représentative de la france en général
et qui manque aussi à michel barnier ex
négociateur en chef du brésil et est
dans la vague du duc au vide puis
déconfinement xavier bertrand il y
vraiment il est sur le terrain de la
réindustrialisation du lien économique
local de cette force des territoires je
trouve que c'est une stratégie qui est
payante on voit d'ailleurs qu'il est
passé en code d'adhésion au dessus de
d'edouard philippe qui lui est vallat a
fait une belle chute à des endroits trop
près des sympathisants droit tout à fait
edouard philippe qui est maire du havre
mais qui a une avantage qui est plus qu
et qui a une image qui est davantage
régaliennes avec une image d'ancien
premier ministre qui quelque part au
culte au culte aujourd'hui c'est à
proximité
pardon je vais je vais citer 1 le
sondage la main d'un autre institut
services interactifs si lille vient de
sortir il nous donne à emmanuel macron
entre 23 et 26 une marine le pen à 16
exavier bertrand à 14 voilà pourquoi je
voulais cité ensuite eric zemmour on va
en parler dans un instant est à 13 comme
jean luc mélenchon anne hidalgo à cette
jadot yannick jadot pardon à si c'était
évidemment avant le résultat de la de la
primaire europe ecologie les verts
pierre jacqmin moi ce que ce que
j'entends en disant je les fais parce
que on est tellement dans la marge
d'erreur mois entre une marine le pen à
14 valérie paix alors moi j'ai page et
on
ne doit pas être très loin peut-être que
c'est dans un autre mais sais tu sais je
reviens à cette question de la
responsabilité et de la république des
sondages c'est pas la première fois
qu'on en parle à chaque présidentielle
ça ressort mais c'est une vraie question
je vais être obligé de devancer le des
bases après celui d'eric zemmour moi je
vole lancé je trouve qu'il ya une
responsabilité certes des médias qui ont
participé certes des hommes et des
femmes politiques qui abondent dans les
idéologies proche de l'extrême droite de
droite et de gauche évidemment mais il
ya aussi la responsabilité des sondeurs
pourquoi tester quelqu'un qui n'est pas
candidat pour quoi tester quelqu'un qui
n'apparaît à l'écran que comme un
polémiste ou comme un journaliste ou
comme un éditorialiste moi ça me pose
question et je pense que cette cet
ensemble des trois des médias des
sondeurs et des hommes politiques qui
participent de la légitimation
problématique de ne pas le considérer
comme un candidat alors qu'il
bénéficiait du décile émission d'une
heure caution objectifs et si on écoute
à la lettre ce que nous dit eric zemmour
il nous dit je ne suis pas candidat à
l'élection présidentielle je suis là
pour vendre un lieu nous avons tous
participé j'ai participé gens portent
les gens portent une partie des à la
responsabilité à débattre autour de la
crédibilité d'un eric zemmour comme
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
sans doute ça y participe quand on débat
aussi avec lui quand on est un
responsable politique même si in fine et
moi j'étais assez sceptique de
l'opportunité de jean luc mélenchon
d'aller faire ce débat je trouve qu'il
me faisait c'était un débat de plutôt
bonne tenue et qui était intéressant
mais quand même
isimat sion sans doute si l'on rit mais
de les intéresser
tous les deux des intérêts évidemment la
légitimation évidemment qu'ils ont
intérêt jean luc mélenchon il a intérêt
à ce que m eric zemmour fasse baisser ce
qui est en train de se passer le sondage
doit que vous découvrez annoncé ce soir
montre que marine le pen baisse
considérablement et que donc le ticket
d'entrée pour le second tour va être
très bas donc tous de jean luc mélenchon
1 valérie pécresse en passant par xavier
bertrand ou encore marine le pen qui on
l'espère j'imagine tous pensent qu'ils
peuvent accéder au second tour comme
jean luc mélenchon en plus c'était à 600
mille voix près proches d'accéder au
second tour lors de la précédent de la
précédente élection présidentielle tout
le monde y croit donc je crois que là il
ya effectivement une responsabilité
générale elle n'est pas de dire c'est la
faute des médias c'est la faute des
politiques non je pense qu'il ya une
responsabilité partagée les sondeurs ou
leurs responsabilités je m'interroge
toujours d'ailleurs je serais curieux de
savoir qu'est ce qui passe dans la tête
des sondeurs pour tester les gommes qui
n'est pas candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui n'est que pour
l'instant un journaliste à elle répond
oui évidemment cette phase surpeuplement
parce que dans ce cas là faut pas faire
de son âge
à partir du moment ou dans les
intentions de vote on teste aucune
personne qui soit candidate quasiment
dans les intentions de vote recoupent
autant je voudrais vraiment du style
vous testiez n'était pas candidat
c'était tout à fait légitime parce qu'on
voyait bien que le parti socialiste il
avait une candidate qui était quasiment
n'est pas un homme politique sectorielle
pour un jeu de dupes de dire qu'il se
prépare pas à la présidence
je veux bien la fin de le comptabiliser
je reviens sur la décision du csa par
hauguel et et de le tester dans les
sandales et je dis ça tout en
reconnaissant qu'il ya une forme de
d'hystérie médiatique autour du
personnage et que l'on connaît très bien
avec laeticia la mécanique on continue
de faire du zemmour parce que vous et
moi ça marche ça fait de l'audience
pardon mais c'est aussi une des raisons
de la mécanique médiatique alors
deux choses dans les intentions de vote
puisque c'est de ces sondages l'avant
vous parler mais dans le baromètre
politique vous verrez que c'est
intéressant d'avoir là ça vous intéresse
sûrement de voir le niveau de popularité
de rejet d'eric zemmour faut bien un
sondage pour apporter cette info mais
dans les intentions de vote il ya très
peu de candidats que nous testions à un
an ou sept mois d'une élection qui ont
déjà dit qu'ils seraient candidats et
deux ou trois la plupart ou trois ou
quatre je sais pas la plupart y compris
emmanuel macron n'est pas candidat il
est pourtant testé alors ensuite votre
question c'est qui fait on rentrait à
partir du moment où une personne n'est
pas dans le champ politique
théoriquement pourquoi le fait-on quand
on l'a fait rentrer parce que son
entourage ses amis tout le monde dit
qu'il est en campagne que vous avez des
affiches dans paris avec monsieur z que
tous les médias disent et si c'était lui
et si zemmour se présentait et qu'à un
moment donné la question se pose de
savoir ce qu'il ferait en termes
d'intentions de vote donc d'ailleurs
nous avons doxa on l'a testé extrêmement
tard on l'a vu
c'était pas très honnête là ce que vous
êtes en train de nous dire parce qu'il a
été testé très tôt eric zemmour très
très très tôt non non mais j'ai jamais
détesté du zemmour si jon super g
moore en intentions de votre nuit
zemmour est testé très tôt parce que
vous avez raison thomas ça excite le
landerneau politico-médiatique alors en
popularité le scénario baron noir serré
qui la belle mare tout le monde mais qui
a été vu par tous tout le milieu
journalistique et politique et même
c'est l'elysée qui à l'époque de baron
noir faisait sortir cette rumeur qu'un
baron noir allait arriver pour 2022
enfin on en est là c'est hystérique vous
avez tout à l'heure où est la
responsabilité à les partager alors vous
verrez il est peut-être sur le baromètre
alors justement on va parler du
baromètre mais je réponds à votre
question de nous nous avons testé la
démo en cette rentrée à un moment où on
a dit compris le csa dit c'est un homme
politique il est candidat donc il est
logique de le tester
et je hais je porte c'est une évidence
je pense aussi qu'il a eu raison bien
évidemment s'agissant d'eric zemmour il
ya deux choses je l'évoquais pour
sandrine rousseau tout à l'heure hélas
les sondages autant je les critiques les
sondages leur rôle sur la droite et le
fait de dire ben attia regardons les
sondages pour choisir notre candidat ça
me semble n'avoir aucun sens ne pas être
la fonction de ce que nous faisons ne
pas être l'objet des sondages autant là
dans le baromètre politique à un moment
donné on remet eric zemmour dirait sans
doute l'église au milieu du village
parce que on a un eric zemmour que l'on
mesure précisément en termes d'adhésion
et de rejet bien sûr il fait le buzz
médiatiquement denso consulting sur
l'analyse et réseaux sociaux nous disent
c'est la personnalité politique à lille
a tout écrasé c'est fou il ya que le
président de la république qui était
plus visible que lui dans la période
récente et y compris dans la période que
vous évoquez avant cet été par exemple
on a vu que lui bien sûr il perce dans
les intentions de vote dans notre
dernière intentions de vote ils étaient
entre 10 et 11 et les récente elle date
de la semaine dernière mais eric zemmour
c'est quelqu'un d'ultra clivant comme on
dit en termes de sondages parfois quand
on parle à des journalistes les gens se
dire mais zemmour ça marche très bien
les gens l'adorent e pas du tout vous
avez 59% des français qui déclarent
ressentir avant tout du rejet à son
égard c'est un terme très fort en
sondages qu'on en voit très rarement sur
notre palmarès du rejet il n'y a guère
que et encore il n'a pas atteint ce
niveau il ya guère que jean luc
mélenchon au plus fort des scandales qui
lie qui avait pu avoir en dix ans je
suis la république où marine le pen qui
approché de pareil niveau et donc vous
allez années après ils ont fait des
scores tout à fait honorable mais c'est
malgré l'église c'est ce que je dis
c'est non mais cette baleine c'est pas
mal mais non c'est pas mal gré c'est
vous avez des personnalité clivante ça
signifie que les 19 % de personnes qui
disent avoir de la sympathie pour ces
mots
franchissent le cap puisque ça
transforme ça en 11% d'intentions de
vote quand vous vous souvenez sarkozy
vous l'aimer ou le détester par l'est de
la france où les met où et bien la
zemmour c'est pareil dray en soit on la
précision le tolère on le supporte à
tous les sens du terme et dans ce cas là
on va jusqu'à peut-être voter pour lui
soit ce qui est le cas de l'immense
majorité des français on le rejette bien
plus qu'on ne rejette marine le pen ou
sachs et ça c'est que vous estimez que
les français vous dise la vérité quand
vous laissant d or ils peuvent tous le
très bien vous dire autre chose et
ferraille faire quand tu as écouté
regardé régionales
on a trois fils ancien mais elle n'était
pas fait de sondage d'intention les
régionales c'est pas c'est pas
uniquement le travail des sondeurs parce
que cela est intéressant quand même moi
je effectivement c'est c'est d'avoir une
cote de rejet aussi aussi élevé c'est
vous nous dites c'est quasiment inédit
ces étudiants d'aujourd'hui dans les
personnalités que vous testez c'est la
personnalité politique la plus rejeter
julia mouzon vous a pas encore entendu
sur sur le voilà sur eric zemmour ce
phénomène médiatique politique alors
pour eux pour boucler du coup c'est sur
cette partie rôle des sondeurs
effectivement les sondages sont une
prophétie auto réalisatrice
voilà comment l'éviter aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas mais par contre c'est c'est
cette deuxième rangée de questions sur
ses côtes de rejet d'appréciation sont
intéressantes parce que ce n'est pas
celle qui font justement l'élection et
le sondage là où peut-être le fait de se
dire que ça libère travail d'étude
valérie pécresse ça peut influencer des
électeurs les codes de rejet cote
d'appréciation c'est des choses qui sont
plus subtiles et qui nous permettent
d'aller plus en profondeur sur le sur
les scores d'eric zemmour eric zemmour à
la star des médias mais c'est pas la
star des français c'était un personnage
qui est donc très clivant c'est un
candidat qui est déconnecté du terrain
qui ne se prononce pas sur les grands
sujets de société que sont par exemple
l'écologie qui va être sur des question
sémantique aller sur le sujet des
prénoms en passant à côté des thèmes qui
font quand même aujourd'hui une très
grande partie de l'actualité politique
française donc on voit un candidat qui
est effectivement porté par une
dynamique médiatique qui vient d'arriver
aussi d'une certaine façon dans cet
espace médiatique en tant que candidat
là où on ne l'attend près d'une heure où
il ya en tout cas c'est comme cela qu'il
va pas sur l'écologie c'est là aucun
intérêt à venir des sujets qu'ils ne
maîtrisent pas tant qu'il n'est pas
candidat en tout cas il est porté par
les médias aujourd'hui
une position qu'on pouvait pas forcément
en tout cas une position de candidature
à venir qu'on n'attendait pas forcément
il ya un an de cet éditorialiste donc
donc une candidature qui est très porté
par les médias qui est très clivante qui
donc fonctionne très bien sur les
réseaux sociaux on sait que les réseaux
sociaux c'est le lieu par excellence de
de l'engagement ce qui crée de
l'engagement la fois que ce soit un like
sur twitter ou un commentaire pour
démonter quelqu'un sur twitter ça va
créer davantage d'engagements donc un
candidat qui est qui est très présent
sur cet espace médiatique mais qu'on ne
retrouve pas effectivement dans une
dynamique convaincante en tout cas
aujourd'hui pour l'élection
présidentielle allez un dernier termine
au reste
environ cinq minutes dans ce premier
débat autour du chef de l'état je
reviens à votre baromètre
gaël le chef de l'état diriez-vous la
question c'est diriez-vous qu emmanuel
macron est un bon président de la
république voilà précisément la question
il est en hausse de 3 points 42% vous
tester aussi son premier mini jean
castex à 40% hausse de deux points alors
un peu un peu d'histoire si ça qu'il a à
sept mois d'un d'une présidentielle
voilà c'est ça qui est intéressant parce
qu'après tout 42 35 ce qui est
intéressant c'est peut-être deux choses
s'agissant emmanuel macron c'est de voir
que c'est un président qui
globalement a basculé dans
l'impopularité assez rapidement il est
parti d'assez haut mais d'un peu moins
haut que ses prédécesseurs et quand on
regarde la courbe qu'on assure sur
internet du baromètre politique on voit
qu'il a basculé dans une impopularité il
tombé très bas autour des 30% n'ayez 7
français sur 10 qui avait une mauvaise
opinion de lui il a conservé des traits
d'image canton le test de manière plus
fine plus détaillée très négatif sur
l'idée du président des riches notamment
en revanche finalement en sortie de
crise decaux vide à sept mois de la
présidentielle
42% de france estimant que c'est un bon
président alors que 58% estiment c'est
un mauvais président on est quand même
dans une dans un personnage qui suscite
plus d'impopularité que ne peut plus
l'arrêter mais 42% c'est mieux que ses
prédécesseurs à pareille époque assez
nettement pour vous donner une idée
c'est deux fois plus que françois
hollande sur le même baromètre à
pareille distance de l'élection donc il
s'en sort pas mal emmanuel macron et lui
pour le moment on verra ce que tout ça
pour le moment tout ce qu'on raconte là
sur zemmour les intentions de vote le
niveau des années ils se frottent les
mains parce que s'il ya bien un gagnant
2 2 laisse pour le moment de cette
situation c'est bien lui qui alors
qu'une majorité de français a quand même
une mauvaise fille en lui il est numéro
un dans les intentions de vote pour le
moment au premier tour et il est donné
gagnant dans toutes les hypothèses
plausibles de second tour pour le moment
donc comme il comme on dit jusqu'ici
tout va bien pour elle même est la même
c'est une popularité paradoxal j'imagine
que vous avez santé de berlin oui il ya
un paradoxe après il ya une réalité
c'est vrai que emmanuel macron a
traversé en un quinquennat qu' aucun
autre présent de la réplique à traverser
alors certes d'eau becuwe d'autres
drames comme le ghana précédent avec les
les attentats dramatique et emmanuel
macron traverse une crise sanitaire
mondiale est certes il ya eu aussi un
mauvais démarrage avec toute la
polémique qui a été qui a existé sur la
question des masques puis après des
tests puis d'après des vaccins mais
globalement je je pense aller au doigt
mouillé pardon je ne suis pas à 100
d'heure mais que les français sont
plutôt satisfaits on voit qu'aujourd'hui
près de la sarre et 70% la population
française est vacciné que les hôpitaux
commencent à être désaturer en tout cas
commence à aller mieux et respirer
davantage même si je sais que les
personnels sont encore beaucoup en
souffrance donc sans doute ça participe
de cette cote de popularité ce moment
d'un état protecteur oui on n'est pas ce
qu'ils sont en vente elle et sa
protectrice que j'entends aussi ce
discours de la gauche aurait fait la
même chose c'est donc une politique de
gauche qui l'a mené j'entends la droite
raconte tout ça il faut pas avoir il
faut pas être donc plus se tromper de
lecture emmanuel macron a fait certes de
quoi qu'il en coûte 1000 a fait un quoi
qu'il en coûte libéral le libéralisme au
sens où l'état se mêle à disposition des
entreprises je crois pas que les
français aient trouvé que pendant cette
période il est mieux vécu ils aient été
utilisés plus se loger plus facilement
il est mieux manger et c'est donc à
disposition
l'emploi pierre jacqmin parce que toutes
les mesures de chômage partiel ça
excellent
papa ya pas eu de vague c'est pour ça
que je vais
pour ça que je dis que c'est le quoi
qu'il en coûte libéral parce que c'est
l'état qui se met à la disposition des
entreprises pour 1000 alors salariés et
de leur sang ce qui se passe dans trois
mois la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte si
les entreprises sont en capacité de
rembourser les emprunts si elles sont en
capacité de maintenir les emplois qu'est
ce qu'il a prévu emmanuel macron là
dessus donc là dessus je pense qu'elle
m'a dit les français vont attendre des
propositions et des solutions par
lavagne mâcon mais vous avez raison les
cotes de popularité me paraît certes
paradoxal mais assez légitime eu égard à
la gestion de la crise même s'il ya
évidemment beaucoup à en dire je pense
que les fonctions non à ranger un
dernier mot peut-être laetitia en fait
sous moi ce que je retiens de cette
analyse qui est passionnante c'est que
évidemment le chef de l'état le prix en
république sont intéressés de rentrer en
campagne le plus tard possible de garder
cette siaap voilà un peu syndicat david
une gamme de protection oui évidemment
de laisser les autres s'écharper de voir
un peu aussi le fait de rentrer très
tard en campagne c'est de voir où sont
ses forces ses faiblesses et où il doit
comment il doit orienter sa stratégie
donc évidemment et n'a aucun intérêt à
rentrer dans l'arène tout de suite hein
et d'ailleurs aucun intérêt à débattre
avec quiconque salé disait le repousse
d'un revers de main et ce sera vraiment
où tout dernier moment et bien sûr que
son bilan sera manifestement
fondamentale vous avez raison ce qu'il a
fait ce sera peut être plus important
que ce qu'il est et ce qu'il le donne en
tout cas comme sentiment aux français on
verra je ne sais pas devant lui ont
donné on est ça on est rarement une
essentielle sur son bilan
à suivre il y aura d'autres débats et
d'autres baromètres vous serez
évidemment le but bienvenu gaël sliman
ou céline bracq qui est qui et votre
adjointe et qui est elle aussi brillante
merci à tous les participants à ce débat
et